il y a un intrus dans notre logiciel
démocratique c'est le temps long
et le tendon se gère pas comme le temps
court et donc oui il faut de la méthode
oui il faut des outils d'évaluation
et puis je dirais aussi
je vais plus l'observer un tout petit
peu quand même pendant mon bref passage
il faut que les moyens qui sont mis en
œuvre
soit adaptés aux objectifs
j'ai trop vu de promesses
avec une forme de sincérité mais dont on
savait où je pouvais pressentir que je
n'en arrêt que je n'aurais pas les
moyens sauf à une révision budgétaire de
les tenir et donc il faut hiérarchiser
aussi les priorités
je
peux prendre un exemple récent parce que
je suis pas là pour juger les décisions
qui sont pris mais c'est pour donner un
ordre d'exemple
le gouvernement dans la hausse du prix
de l'énergie récemment
a pris une mesure je crois que c'est
[Musique]
5 milliards d'euros pour mettre en place
le bouquet tarifaire
bon mais sur ce sujet qui est le vôtre
et notamment pour accompagner les
dispositifs qui sont déjà en place on en
met 18 fois moins donc voilà moi je
pense et je vais en terminer
votre sujet et c'est pas pour vous
flatter mais c'est un sujet central
pourquoi parce que et ça c'est ma
conviction profonde
toute politique énergétique quel que
soit ce que
l'exécutif et législatif vont décider
elle est conditionnée par la sobriété et
l'efficacité énergétique
vous pouvez mettre du tout nucléaire si
vous dit ou du tout du tout
renouvelable
et d'ailleurs cet objectif est inscrit
dans la loi je le rappelle parce qu'il
me semble qu'on l'a on l'a oublié et
donc l'efficacité énergétique et
notamment dans le bâtiment parce que
c'est là que
la plus grande source d'économie donc
c'est prioritaire ces prioritaires parce
que voilà souvent on a opposé écologie
et social là je vais vous dire
effectivement c'est une mesure sociale
parce que on découvre pas vous mais on a
découvert un peu tard la précarité
énergétique elle est de pire en pire
notamment avec cette envolée des prix
et
troisièmement on sait que le bâtiment
rentre pour
on est 44% dans la consommation
d'énergie primaire et 27% dans la
production des gaz à effet de serre donc
on est vraiment
au cœur d'une problématique qu'à sa
raison d'être et sur lequel à mon avis
il faut
pas baisser la garde au contraire